بعيدا عن السياسه واشنطن تختبر نوايا بكين
اداره الرئيس جو بايدن اعلنتها صراحه
وقررت تعزيز التعاون مع الصين لوقف دخول
ماده الفانتان الى المخدرة الى الولايات
المتحده بوند قد يكون اساسيا على جدول
اعمال زياره وزير الخارجيه انطوني بلينكن
الى بكين الفانتانيل صناعي اقوى من
الهيروين بما يصل الى 50 مره يتم خلطه مع
مخدرات غير قانونيه اخرى معدل الوفيات
الناجمه عن تعاطي جرعات زائده من
الفانتانيل ارتفع لاكثر من ثلاثه امثاله
بين عامي 2016
حسب المراكز الاميركيه لمكافحه الامراض
والوقايه منها واشنطن تضع منع دخول المواد
المستخدمه في صنع الفانتان الى القادمه من
الصين ضمن اولوياتها غير ان المسؤولين
الامريكيين يرون ان نظرائهم الصينيين لا
يب دون حماسا كبيرا للتعاون
بلاينكن سيكون اكبر مسؤول بالحكومه
الامريكيه يزور الصين منذ تولي الرئيس
بايدن السلطه
بلال البشتين العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه وال
وثائق يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات